okay giving me all the Christmas gifts
this wasn't my ass we are bringing
Christmas early to hammerlock it's
coming in late we've been really
dressing we've been doing things yeah
your sushi Lobby or maybe didn't catch
up one time and then Beauty and the
Beast yes and who was the Beast you know
you guys are both Beauty and the Beast
all together tell me how much fun you're
having it I heard anybody are really
excited to see your meat um what was
really cool scene just so in perform and
right now he's doing an acoustic set I'm
like what yeah yeah and I love Luke
Bryan and the fact that we get to
present him tonight I am like I just
need some country girl shake it for me a
drama club on you and country and
wrestling really go hand in hand
[Laughter]
got a little country and yes what do you
guys have coming up next tell me where
things are out with the show well so
total divas Season eight just premiered
and I can't believe we're in season
eight it's crazy it feels like so many
years and right now we are filming total
Bella's season four which is amazing and
then we decided because we are teaming
with Ronda Rousey for one of the biggest
shows in Australia and so excited I
think we make a good team the belly
aroused yeah I love this girl power now
filming season four of total Bella's
what are we gonna see on that journey
because you guys have been so open about
your lives and we know you've gone
through a lot of ups and downs recently
what will we see a lot of ups this
season which is great it's um you know I
think brie and I both are on just this
incredible journey I think I feel like
it's gonna be in a very empowering
season just her being back in the ring
as a mom and everything that she goes
through being a mom that travels on the
road but you know your body changes and
how you get back into that and then I'm
back where my home is and my family and
with those roots and just to even share
the ring with someone like Ronda Rousey
and all the other women of WWE but then
just being me and
you know having that journey I gotta ask
cuz you look gorgeous we've heard you're
dating are you dating and what are you
looking for it I got what so I I this is
where I have to learn to keep my mouth
shut I made a joke about dating Netflix
and black licorice and I said it kind of
gets boring and then it turned in this
thing and I got quoted saying dating
life is born and I was like no that was
about Netflix and licorice I was like oh
great I get this boring but no I mean I
love it but meaning like it wasn't
exciting what people are expecting so I
have to man I mean I am single but I'm
I'm not ready for me going yet you know
I I don't know yourself first I do yeah
do you I feel like I saw you
instagramming like on a vacation by a
lake like have you taken trips kind of
rediscovered yourself what are you doing
in that arena Oh totally you know that's
something that actually you're gonna see
on total divas but Lake Tahoe to me is
such a magical place and that's like
kind of where I started that in Palm
Springs to just refresh my soul and I
mean being back at WTI I'm seeing a new
city every week so I'm just trying to
soak everything that life has to offer
me right now well I love you as a sister
being like you got to find yourself do
you feel what do you need to find out
about yourself what's next oh goodness
um I think I just I feel like I've I'm
at that age where I'm discovering who I
really am and what do I want out of life
and just like independence and I'm
enjoying it mocking allies it's scary
and you have these moments of like what
am i doing and you have fear but I just
I kind of am liking the challenge and
that fear because it's just sports gonna
be out of my comfort zone it's kind of
like dancing I got so forced outside of
my comfort zone and I feel like I'm
doing the same right now not that you
lose yourself but you do have to find
yourself again is that how you're
feeling 100% and I feel like I'm slowly
finding that which is
some minutes cool because she's kind in
the same boat because being a mom like
her life is is so much birdies kind of
doing it together with just hello you've
got our old selves I'm I got her up
there lotta money well there's I mean
ever in Vegas we go out but I know I
don't want the hangovers oh yeah we know
so just finding yourself mean finding
out what you really want a guy yes just
and I think for me it's a happiness like
just fully being happy and so that's
what I really want
well where are you in John do you text
you talk at all how are things
uh we don't so yeah we just he's doing
him and I'm doing me we also want to ask
you about another important guy Artem
new season of Dancing with the Stars
sending your love his way texting him
when you do much I do I was so like when
they did the Good Morning America
announcement fact that he's dancing with
someone who's blind is I think
absolutely amazing not only for Artemev
for Dancing with the Stars and I've
looked at all of Danielle stuff and I
think she is such an incredible woman
and I'm she got the best partner and I'm
not being biased because he was my part
you are no but I think he is the best
Pro to have someone like that and I just
know they're gonna create magic on that
dance floor and even though I'm gonna be
at Monday Night Raw Monday night so I'm
gonna miss them I wish I could be there
to support them so vote for our diamond
Danielle last question guys just tell us
why should we watch a total divas the
new season in a couple Oh
Sonne a couple working you wanna mood
yeah if you want to be inspired
empowered and I feel like laughing you
know enjoy your popcorn watching little
drama then tune in total divas
[Music]